in esports peripherals
are
everything from mice to keyboards
monitors and even mouse pads gamers will
go out of their way to customize
practically any part of their setup in
the hope that it might just give them
some sort of advantage over their
opponents some start off basic by trying
out different products of various shapes
and sizes while other diy deities make
it their mission to design personalized
peripherals that most of us could only
dream of 3 500 keyboard
dude this thing is nuts oh my god look
at dude it's so clean you guys can reach
out through it how clean it is you know
i can't wait to put this in my bathroom
and then shave with this mirror on the
back but not everyone cares to use the
newest and shiniest custom peripherals
out there hell some of us enjoy living
in the past i started using it after my
first mouse broke and i didn't have like
another mouse at my
home so i was just like grabbing the
next mouse i can possibly get it was
happened to be a trackball but very few
players have managed to compete and even
win on esports's biggest stages using
peripherals that are
well
weird and when they do manage to make it
work it is often quite spectacular okay
goes for a good time a baby conversion
the ghetto combo
does get a combo hard knocked out oh
just do super the club did this get him
it got him
[Applause]
and the burst beat
initial t he lost his burst there every
time oh my goodness so on this week's
episode of cracked we are taking a look
at the
oddest peripherals ever used in esports
and posing the question
are they viable or were they just
used as a joke
[Applause]
okay so before we dive into this week's
episode i must humbly request as usual
that you like the video subscribe to the
channel and if it's something you think
you'd be into turning on notifications
we are very close to 2 million subs and
you could help us get there who knows
maybe when we hit 2 million subs i will
start using a wireless mouse i'm not
going to start using wireless mouse so
i'm sure i don't have to tell any of you
that gamers have been tinkering with
each and every aspect of their setup for
quite literally
decades whether it's adjusting their
in-game sensitivity or literally taking
apart their controller gamers will do
just about anything to stand out some do
it for performance of course but others
do it to make the game they love just
that bit more accessible take seth
killian for instance he is known for
playing fighting games with his
quote-unquote cross-hand method where he
places his left hand on the buttons and
his right hand on the control stick and
while it might look
kinda weird for players like seth it
just
feels more natural as we mentioned in
our episode about left-handed gamers
adopting such an unorthodox grip style
has actually made certain fighting games
easier to pick up for lefties enough for
me it's time that you listen to the
guy who you know just knows what just
run the stupid title card and now the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about okay using wacky peripherals is
all fine and good but how are people
competing at the top of their games with
these things
well one piece we should probably talk
about is muscle memory we bring it up
all the time like in our left-handed
gamers episode or most recently in our
episode on mouse acceleration but we've
never really talked about what muscle
memory is or how it even works now
obviously your muscles don't actually
have the ability to store memories so
the piece doing all the work behind the
heavy lifting is your brain every muscle
movement starts there with an electrical
signal since your brain is constantly
looking for ways to do its job more
efficiently it will naturally begin to
store commonly used movements and series
of movements so that they can be
recalled quickly without as much effort
also fun fact your brain does almost all
of this when you aren't practicing the
thing you want to remember so take
breaks and get lots of sleep but how
exactly does this relate to gamers using
preposterous peripherals well allow me
one more detour into the realm of music
since long before there were heads to
click in your fps of choice musicians
have been learning and mastering some
incredibly complex and intricate hand
and finger movements and just like
gamers we see musicians gravitate
towards different shapes and sizes of
their chosen instrument even though
they're putting those same notes and
chords into memory each person's fingers
hands wrists and so on are all different
and they will tend to play those notes
and chords in different more comfortable
ways and that right there is the key
that could actually help you now am i
saying you should be slamming out your
valor and ranked games on a set of rock
band drums i mean [ __ ] if you can do
that you should definitely do that that
would be cool as hell
right that's not the point what
experimenting with weird peripherals can
do is give you some insights into what
sorts of movements shapes and positions
are most comfortable so you can find
peripherals that work best and help you
reach the top of your game and that was
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about whether it's for the
purposes of accessibility or just pure
entertainment the fighting game
community in particular has used some of
the weirdest peripherals at events back
in 2014
a street fighter 4 player named luffy
shocked the world when he won evo with a
playstation 1 controller and luffy uses
some meter for an ex fireball so no more
soul spiral in the supers but bonchan
also had a meter
oh no oh no
he has taken evolution 2014. now some of
you may be thinking that a ps1 gamepad
actually seems pretty tame but let me
assure you for a game like street
fighter
it is very out of the ordinary since the
playstation 1 is basically
ancient at this point luffy had to use a
lag-free ps1 converter to play the game
properly while his opponents just had to
plug in their fight sticks or pads some
street fighter competitors like santorum
and have actually memed on him for his
controller selection
since then we've seen even crazier
peripherals pop up in the fgc from
guitar hero controllers to gamecube
keyboards and whatever the hell this is
fighting game enthusiasts have perhaps
taken things a little too far but at the
2018 canada cup a player named initial t
did the unthinkable he managed to take
down the 2017 guilty gear champion
dogura with a steering wheel yes you
heard me this dude plays guilty gear
with a
steering wheel hey goes for a good time
a baby conversion the ghetto combo does
get a combo hard knocked out just do
super the club did this get him it got
him
[Applause]
he lost his burst there every time oh my
goodness now thanks to an interview he
did with gerald of core a gaming we were
given a little insight as to why initial
tv does this so it all kind of started
on our local discord
i bought this to actually play racing
games on
but when i showed it to people on
discord they were just like but can you
play fighting games on it and i was like
why not i'll give it a try so i booted
up guilty gear with this tried some
hanging combos and i was just like okay
it works well enough
so then everybody started egging me on
oh you better bring this to cat in the
cup and better play your pools with this
so i was like okay i guess i'm doing it
i know what all of you are wondering
does initial t control his character by
physically turning the steering wheel
sadly
the answer is no although he is able to
control the side to side movement of his
character by turning the wheel he opts
to use the d-pad for movement and the
paddle shifter and other buttons to
fight but while the fighting game
community continues to try out these
large and clunky peripherals competitors
from other esports titles are on a quest
to find lighter and smaller options tkl
75 and 60 keyboards are becoming
increasingly popular with gamers because
of their small form factors while many
zoomers particularly in the fps space
just want their mice to be as light as
possible clickers like the super light
razer viper ultimate and various final
mouse products have set an insane
standard when it comes to weight some of
them ship as light as 60 grams and who
knows we might even see more weight
shaved off in future iterations but
since not everyone can afford their
fairly high price tags some gamers will
go to some pretty extreme lengths to
cut off
some of that weight i can almost promise
you i have the most scuffed mouse ever
alright let's take a general look at it
so first and foremost this is a model o
i chop the back off i don't need it i
hold the mouse like this i like to do
precision movements with my fingers so i
don't need the back the rubber
double-sided tape here
is actually just for reshaping as you
can see it cups my thumb perfectly now
same with these fingers and especially
my pinky because before it was too
narrow and make my pinky hurt so bad
after playing for a while so this
widening it up it's perfect as for the
mouse feet i have one glorious ceramic
foot because i lost one of these ones
and these ones are from an old logitech
g500 that i cut out
now most people aren't
sawing their [ __ ] in half like boney tv
but if you do prefer some smaller form
factors there are definitely some other
options out there for you take moth for
instance he's a former support player
for overwatch rosters like the san
francisco shock la gladiators and even
team usa and back in 2019 he spoke to us
about his rather strange keyboard setup
my setup might be a little bit weird for
some people i've got like a split
keyboard and i use a wooden wrist rest
on the left hand and i have two mouse
pads stacked on one another and i've
been doing that for a very long time
it's just like what's comfortable to me
and
it's something i've gotten used to so
i'm not really comfortable playing on a
different setup i can move the left side
separately from the right side so i can
like put it wherever i want on the desk
and i have like empty space in the
middle i just like that better than
having the keyboard take up all the
space
but these
odd play styles and peripherals aren't
exclusive to fighting games and hero
shooters no no matter what game you play
comfort is key to performing at your
best and within the speed running
community this is especially true when
every second and sometimes even
milliseconds can make all the difference
players are always looking for ways to
improve their efficiency within the
server and among the endless sea of
speed running savants is a man who goes
by the moniker angelus deminus he runs
the most difficult solo content in final
fantasy xiv despite the fact that said
content was never actually designed to
be soloed hell nobody even managed to
solo some of this content for nearly two
years after the deep dungeons release a
single run in the original deep dungeon
can take players anywhere from 12 to 16
hours to complete and about half that
time for the follow up version heaven on
high now these time limited runs are an
exercise in risk management and they're
extremely unforgiving if at any point
you happen to die then you must start
all the way back from the beginning
barring specific rare items that need to
be conserved to succeed there are no
second chances oh and not to mention
that there are randomized layouts and
items so rng can also play a huge factor
and angelus demonas sits second on the
ether solo leaderboard but what is
particularly impressive is that he has
secured this spot
without the use of a mouse first off uh
we have my general movement and my
general movement is the basic super
standard w a s d so c is just the normal
movement w is forward s is back uh a d
is left and right and this is where it
gets top um interesting is with my
camera movement my camera movement is
set to uh the minus sign where the cam
camera moves up the open brackets where
the camera moves down uh p spins the
camera to the left and then the closed
brackets spin the camera to the right
now the vast majority of pc mmo players
are accustomed to the standard mouse and
keyboard so we decided to sit down with
angelus and ask him why he opted to
forgo the former at the time 11 came out
it was when i was in college and i was a
lot of times i was in college and stuff
so i had a laptop on me
um and it was just convenient that way
but 11
was not the greatest with the mouse
support it just was more like a
controller game-ish but also when you
kind of use the mouse it was just kind
of dull so i kind of just figured out a
way to do with my keyboard and that's
kind of how it first started that
adaptation became part of his play style
and when 14 released it featured a lot
of accessibility options to support both
gamepad and pc peripherals so he was
able to replicate his experience in the
newer mmo even if it isn't everyone's
cup of tea having both hands and your
keyboard can have some benefits like
more precise targeting one of the worst
parts of ff14's interface and let's not
forget this is a challenge where every
second counts
my spins down
okay
i'm gonna time out on 100
i'm gonna timeout on 100 i don't have
enough time to reach the to exit and go
oh my god
i don't have anything
this is going to be the tragic ending
i'm not making it
what oh my god
what angelus demonis might not have
expected is that his strange method of
playing the game has actually made final
fantasy much more accessible to other
players and even if they don't adopt his
playstyle as a whole they can learn
lessons about how to tweak their own but
no matter what type of games you play
you can always find somebody who is
breaking the norm players who push the
boundaries of what is and isn't possible
by using obscure methods to compete for
some of them it's just an attempt to
stand out and prove to themselves that
what they're doing is actually viable
while for others their style of play
doesn't seem all that strange to them
they're unorthodox setups or keybinds
have allowed them to comfortably play
and sometimes even compete at the
highest level in the games that they
love nowadays most games allow you to
customize everything for pc gamers in
particular the freedom to change
basically any part of your gameplay is
honestly extremely appealing so next
time you see somebody running a super
weird peripheral or keybinds or whatever
don't be so quick to judge
sure they might be crazy but
they might also be onto something
yeah i play cs and valorent with
knife on q primary on e and pistol on x
and i use mouse buttons for nades and
numbers but people think it's really
weird i don't know i've just played
counters like that counter-strike like
that for years i just carried it over i
still i play cs go like that i play
power it like that i just i don't know
it works for me it feels the most
natural for me and i'm pretty good i'd
like to think i'm pretty good my rank's
saying pretty good